okay so we're back at it
opponent today is the one and only anish
giri
who won a thrilling match to beat peter
svidler
and make it to the to the quarterfinals
so without further ado let's get the
games going
we're going to play d4 and
in the first game probably gonna see
some kind of
of queen's gambit here i think
but
understandably since i made him wait for
a couple of minutes to get going he's
going to make me
wait a little bit as well little mind
games you know
igor goes for the ragosan as he has done
many many times
uh and
what is my idea here
okay let's play e3
let's see if he uh if he started this
i can tell you for sure that i haven't i
think he faced this against stephen
chuck
if i'm not completely mistaken
quincy 2 is a bit stupid but i guess
it's a
it's kind of a waiting move
um otherwise you probably would move the
f1 bishop and then
you would sort of lose a tempo
okay now after knight c6 i don't know
what to do
this is a bummer of course
i'll go a4
traditionally i don't think he
he like really punishes
[Music]
ambitious opening play so i think there
is some chance that i could
could get away with this now obviously
the intention is to go bishop a3 next
and if cd4 i go cd4 and i hope that the
the weakening of the b4 square is not
that big a deal
dc4 obviously i developed developed the
bishop in one go
and if b6 um
yeah so rook e8 having all that
in mind is a very logical
waiting move i think i'll take on d5
and then
[Music]
probably
there's something that is to be said for
bishop e5 i think
probably i'll just take him i'll just
take on c5
if queen a5 i do have the option of
going bishop b5
so now i think bishop d3
and if it does take i
on c5 i think it would have been greedy
and uh
and taken upon an h7
and now speaking of greedy i think i
should be consistent
and defend this pawn
he does have some play with bishop g4
but
i was hoping that i could just castle
then
also maybe bishop g4 knight d4 is not so
bad
an 85 i can then maybe castle if it
takes the knight
if he takes the bishop i take back and i
have f3 so it might be a little bit
better there
additionally he might go queen a5 now
but then i think i castle
if he takes on c5 i go bishop b5
with knight d4 to come possibly
um and if knight c3
i don't really know but there should be
there should be many options
queen a5 feels a little bit soft
it's getting shorter in time
okay so finally it takes it takes c5
but now i guess i certainly have the
the initiative here knight d4
is quite tempting bishop d7 though
f6 f3 maybe you can take on c3
but also just knife sex
i guess i'll go c4 instead
oh a6 was unexpected
hmm
cda ab dc6 does not seem
yeah this was
probably a bit less than i'd i hoped for
to
to be honest
i'm finding it a little bit hard to
to coordinate my my forces in
in a way that i like bishop d7 is coming
next
okay
yeah probably he handled this
candles as well with uh with a6
i should speed up a bit
okay i'm going to do one
no no i'm not
i'm not better anymore
it's absolutely fine
which is of course a less than ideal
development
he did have bishop g4 there okay
obviously bishop chief
e5 just to confuse him a bit
you can take a4 but i took d5 i don't
think that's a disaster bishop c6 back
because now he's intending to push the
pawn
maybe he can take f2 okay he didn't
uh yeah this is gonna be
a bit of a battle of nerves
quite like the fact that he oh this one
is no good
now there's a double threat of taking a
g7 and also
and also there was a fork
yeah now i'm
considerably better with the pawn up
okay five
g3
knight before i think he's losing that
pawn now
rook b8 don't cannot be played because
of the pin i just taken f7
so now he's two pawns down
[Music]
that should be plenty for me to win the
game
okay we'll push e4
97 don't go f4 maybe
98 it's a lot better
okay
oh he's fighting gotta give him that
but i think it's uh it's an
uphill battle to say the least
i'll take this take on a five that's
three points up now
and he resigns
that was uh that wasn't true
that was a nervy battle